thank you
[Music]
so a famous a very famous celebrities
gold digging [__] has emerged who is it
so you guys know who Kevin Costner is
yeah oh yeah so his he has he has a gold
digging [__] of a ex-wife who he is
divorcing
for being a gold digging yeah really
are you sure yeah are you sure this is
her
do you think if Joseph looks alone is
this she is
I thought she was an actress does she
have her own like independent success oh
no I was thinking she looks like Tori
Spelling when you look at her do you
think she looks like a gold digging horn
I think
um that she is a gold digging [__] yeah
do you think it's easy I think she's
actually a gold digger what's wow just
off looks huh just off the looks just
off the looks that's that's the thing
why what makes them what what makes her
because I was reading about about her in
the Daily Mirror oh reputable Source
yeah yeah and so now I know for a fact
that it's true yep ah yeah so she um her
and uh Kevin Costner's Kevin Costner no
leave it that for now on yeah never say
Costner again Kevin Costner
hurry Kevin cost us we're together for
for a while how long uh many many years
she's playing the long game huh she
played the long game for sure that's
some gold digging hard Tendencies
exactly go do that Anna Nicole Smith she
played along Oh They'll be there for
like 40 years sometimes well this
particular article is mentioning how she
has emerged right so she she has emerged
and she's holding like a really
expensive purse like she's coming out
how does one emerge as a gold digging
horse well if you're if you're not
around and then you come out of your
house that you have emerged because
she's been hiding in the house cave so
this particular gold digging [__] comes
out right and
she's got a really nice Prada back oh
how much are those it's a huge tell it's
like it's called it's a clear it's a
clue yeah yeah that's a clue they always
got some fancy bags that hardcore though
because it's not her mess
Birkin is very expensive right how much
is a Prada bag run it's cheap 25k
because that's how much a Birkin is huh
definitely it's definitely about 10 G's
yeah definitely about 10 cheese but yeah
so when I was I didn't know who this
chick was I knew who Kevin Costner's was
for a long time but I didn't know who
she was but now that I read this Daily
Mirror article I know everything about
her and seeing the little clue the
little context clue of her wearing
holding this expensive purse tells me
everything I needed to know right
because it's not like she's not doing
Gucci or something more normal yep for a
celebrity of that caliber so she wasn't
and she wasn't part of any Charities or
things that like some rich dudes Gold
Digging [__] do it doesn't say it just
says what what a gold digging [__]
[__] she is
over and over and over how do you
believe you yeah yeah yeah
I'm with you you Steve if she's that
rich
Kevin's Costner if she had a Kate Spade
back then everybody everyone would have
been like oh she loves him for him
exactly because he's she has a they're
they're millionaires yep and she has a
Kate Spade bag hey just go go something
a little cheaper dude there's just not
much info about her I don't even know
what her name is
for example I just know she's Kevin
Costner's wife ex-wife are they they're
going through a difference it's official
the divorce it's official so they um so
he is 68 years old they had 18 years of
marriage and their breakup uh has not
been amicable uh apparently Mr costness
has been fighting together to get her to
vacate their 145 million dollar Santa
Barbara wow and I will say not to brag
but my in-laws have a one million dollar
home in Santa Barbara and it might as
well be 800 square feet so you you can
imagine what 145. it's insane that's
probably they got five bedrooms Steve
can go in the living room and touch it
but she's got to move out they probably
can't even see each other TV Cribs of
Kevin Costner's back in the day yeah me
too it's the Santa Barbara house it's
along the it's like on the cliff along
the beach and it's big enough to ride a
horse back and forth she's crazy huh I'm
like damn you have a [__] horse
trainer
18 years ago that's around the Times MTV
Cribs was very popular she was probably
watching TRL and then next thing that
shows up is MTV Chris with Kevin cost
because that's how they do it we figured
it out already that's how gold diggers
do it they just watch all the stuff and
they go oh he's Rich the scheme and then
they go I'm gonna make him fall in love
with you I'm gonna ride a horse on that
yep she's like 18 years is probably
enough and then I can break up with him
and then
yeah what do you think your chances are
of getting half 50 50. but some but some
gold diggers are dumb because maybe 100
because some gold diggers are dumb
because on the way to getting the guy
they make a lot because they needed to
sustain their bills so they make a lot
of money and then they get with the guy
and then when it's 50 50 they have to
end up because they suck at math too
they have to give a lot of what they
made and they don't it actually doesn't
even give half of what they made to the
guy now yeah yeah and then they so
they're like a reverse gold digger too
good at being gold diggers that they
they've dug gold elsewhere through like
a career or something yeah they saved
all this money up they got with their
target oh and then they got gold they
did the long game maybe 40 years and
then they broke up with um but then now
she has to give up half but she made
more because she didn't she didn't plan
her Target alcohol is that how that
works I was reading in the TMZ comments
yeah what did they say so so she right
so she yeah
but she conveniently waited for him to
be on this hit show Yellowstone and then
she decides to dump and that's what this
chick was saying in the TMZ so he was
making tons of money exactly raking it
in yep oh he's in Yellowstone huh
because he was kind of his career was
kind of on a downswing for a while right
obviously but then just with Yellowstone
Yellowstone's a good people did he did
he produce is he a producer of that show
yeah it's a hit show so he had to put
money into it he's double dipping dude
oh wow is it about the geysers there I
think so no it's not Yellowstone Montana
I think it's not the national park it's
about Yellowstone Africa oh okay I have
tons of geysers there it's just a geyser
show yeah
[Laughter]
we all did it at Yellowstone everyone
dude it's you just stand there and you
wait and then I think every week they
just throw new things into the geyser
and see yeah but I think it's not about
the national park I think so there's no
Buffalo there's no guys he doesn't watch
TV this guy no I think it's Yellowstone
ranch or something right but we're gonna
take this one dude just take a back seat
has anyone done that bit at
Yellowstone's or at the geysers where
you go like
I think the tour guide does that part
the park ranger does it
or he's like holy [__]
park ranger he was so good he did the
girl voice and the guy boys really yeah
that's good
he went oh
and then me and my mom
will like both
when you and Dad do it it's like when
someone sings Aladdin for both parts
like you know when people do the Leaning
Tower of Pizza yeah he [__] laid down
right in the right position and then
yeah this guy just can [__] you up
though right yeah oh yeah [__] you up
it's real hot you gotta stay away sit on
that thing
not like a jacuzzi tub right
so pretty much this is about this gold
digging [__]
and yeah read all about it mostly
through all the comments and what
peoples was speculated about what do
people what do the people say oh just I
mean Jesus she was in for money
obviously because he's a very rich
person and they have three kids together
and then she divorced him at exactly the
height of his career Resurgence wow yeah
so she could get Max dollars yep but she
has a job right
I think it's been gold digging [__]
the last tax filing said yeah that's how
she files her taxes career earnings
through the roof yeah
when she goes for a credit card
information and then they're like
occupation she goes gold digging [__]
she's like there's no there's no option
for gold digging [__] she's a yeah she's
a customer
[Laughter]
yeah she's a heck of a time when the
census guy comes to the door yeah
yeah I'm really glad we have breaking
news like this that
you know we let people know watch out
for them gold digging slots go deeper
yeah we did a lot of research on this
one so yeah yeah see you guys in the
next one